Hey guys, and welcome to a brand new
series. Uh now, this is something uh
that was suggested in the comment
section a week or two ago, and I was
contacted by a member of the clan chat,
and he really helped me flush out
this idea of a grand exchange only
series. Now, what this would be is um I
would have access to the grand exchange,
and a couple other locations will be
unlockable down the road. I could train
any skill
in the grand exchange or this next area,
and I would be able to use the grand
exchange for flipping.
I'll be able to use it for money making
and any skills I can do in there. Uh
there trees, you know. I would be
confined to the area, but it would be a
really interesting challenge. So, I
decided to end actually end up doing it.
So, this is going to be episode one.
Uh the restrictions are going to be, of
course, area, which I'll show you in a
minute.
No trading. I'm allowed to pick up
drops,
but obviously
only drops of random people.
Not going to drop my character own
items, of course.
Um there's going to be trees in the
grand exchange. Those are fair grabs.
All right, so I have the character
through uh tutorial island. So, I'll go
ahead and show you the map as the
location I'm allowed to move around and
explain a little bit more about the
challenge. All right, so for the GE only
challenge, I'm obviously going to start
in the starting zone. Now, that is the
grand exchange. Uh I will be confined
here until I have reached a total level
of at least 250,
which will then unlock the palace.
Uh so, in the grand exchange I'll only
be able to trade or train uh like fire
making, cooking,
um
wood cutting, crafting, and I'll have to
get those combined skills to a total
level at least 250, and then I can
proceed to the palace.
In the palace, there are going to be a
couple other options to train, mainly
melee cuz there will be guards there. Uh
even magic. I'm not sure if I can get
magic in the grand exchange. We'll have
to see. Even the tree farming patch,
which will be unlocked at 300 total
level, is doable. And the way this is
going to work is I'm going to have to
use a rake on the farming patch until I
get to level 15 for oak trees. And on
top of that, there are going to be two
Bible skills. So, to unlock these
skills, I will need to pay 10 mil for
either
my player owned home or herblore. As you
can see, the POH is right outside the
palace, so it's pretty close. And
herblore,
yes, I'm going to have to go and unlock
it, but
it's is just part of the challenge. So,
I know technically I will have but
you'll have to forgive me. All right,
that's it, guys. So, no leaving the
grand exchange. The goals will be here
at the side. We'll display them at the
beginning of each episode just to see
where we're at. And a huge shout-out to
Wing Statue. He was the guy who ended up
designing this map for me and helping me
out with flushing out the series. So,
his Twitter handle will be in the
description. Go check him out for sure.
And also, the original idea for this was
done actually by Beascape already.
So, he also did this. So, if you want to
have a look at how he did it, a link for
his first video will be in the
description as well. All right, let's
get started. Okay, guys. So, I got my
brand new account to the grand exchange.
You can see I literally have 32 total
level. Nothing's been progressed. I ran
straight here pretty well. And uh yes,
we're going to get started. First off,
we're going to need to grab some ashes
off the ground since we pretty much
liquidated everything in our bank as
well. I actually forgot to get rid of
our equipment, but that's not a huge
deal.
Uh so, yeah. Unfortunately, we don't
even have enough for an axe, so at least
we're going to have to pick up some
ashes. And uh we're going to pick up
just anything we can find in the grand
exchange just to get a couple hundred GP
to start with, and then we're going to
go ahead and buy an axe and start wood
cutting. All right, so we have a full
inventory of ash, and we've sold off a
couple extra items we found,
which is going to lead us to have about
1.2k.
Our first 1k cash stack, great.
So, now we're going to go ahead and buy
an iron axe cuz that's the only one I
can equip right now. And oh my god,
these things are expensive.
So, I'll go for 500, I guess. And yeah,
so for the GE portion of this before I
unlock the palace, all I can cut is
regular trees, so this is going to kind
of suck. All right, there's level five
wood cutting. Uh fortunately, once we
get
out of this GE section, there is an oak
tree. So, probably not going to grind
out the wood cutting too much, although
we might need it for total levels. All
right, and no logs wasted. Logs are
actually worth like 40 each, so actually
that's going to add to our cash stack,
which is nice. That's about 1,000 coins
in logs right there. Not bad. All right,
so apparently, guys, there are imps in
here. I just saw this imp, so I
sped over to the grand exchange and
bought some rune spells. I've never been
been this excited to see an imp cuz this
means once I get my magic to level four,
I'm safe. I can then train it without
having to find random encounters like
this.
Oh, I hope he's still in here.
We're going to have to Maybe we can
splash him, but oh my god, he's outside.
Ooh, don't run out. Uh that was fine.
But yeah, so we're going to be able to
level up our magic actually cuz the imps
do roam around here a fair amount. So,
yeah. Ideally, we'll splash, but
hopefully we can just get to level four
magic and then we'll be safe. Oh my god,
I'm like spark mag right now.
Get the imp. I got level two magic. Only
two more magic levels.
Ooh, he's just barely out there. All
right, there's level three magic. Only
one more to go, but I think we're going
to kill the imp before we actually level
four, unfortunately. All right, guys.
We're actually going to get four magic,
so that's exciting cuz now I can enchant
crossbow bolts, and I can do that right
from the grand exchange if I have to.
I'd prefer to get my magic up a little
bit more and
Uh but yeah, so now I'm safe. I'm free
to level up my magic as I will and as I
have the right amount of money, we can
enchant opal. All right, there we go.
We've gotten our wood cutting to 15. Uh
still going pretty quickly, but it's
going to slow down soon because all
we're cutting is [__] trees. So, I
think we're going to cut the logs in our
bank just for some quick fletching
levels. We're going to make arrow
shafts, but I don't know how much
they're actually going to be worth. All
right, five fletching off of those.
Unfortunately, the arrow shafts are only
worth one GP each, so it's kind of a
waste. All right, so we cornered an imp
in here, and we have enough gear to
splash. We went and bought full iron.
So, we're going to be able to actually
get Uh well, I think the earliest
enchant spell that's not the enchant
bolts is the level one enchant, which
should be level 12 or something. It's
not very high. All right, there we go.
Our magic is level seven. That is
actually enough for the level one
enchant. I was 100% wrong. So, I'm not
planning on training my combat up while
I'm in the initial zone because it's
going to take a while to get it to a
high level. But since there are some
imps here, I'm definitely going to punch
my way maybe to level 10 attack,
strength, defense, and range just
because that's a lot easy free total
levels. Uh whereas the other ones will
take a lot longer. So, yeah, we'll
probably get our combats to 10. All
right, there is level 20 wood cutting,
and I do realize I missed this genie
random. I was not paying attention, but
I really need to be on these cuz these
are going to give me experience in I
guess thieving cuz there's a way I could
get my thieving up
like eventually. I don't know if this is
going to be possible. Maybe I can splash
a man somewhere close. I don't know.
Anyway, I should have gotten that anyway
to put it in a skill, but I forgot. All
right, and we're putting in a couple
flips,
our first flips. We only had about 5 or
10k to work with cuz of the logs we've
been selling as well as the ashes. The
elemental talisman and the leprechaun
hat is what we're going with. Super
cheap items and have a pretty good
margin. Okay, so we completely changed
the item we're going with. We're going
with the ancient stole now. We actually
managed to get three of these before we
even sold our arrow shafts. So, that is
That tells you something.
So, we bought them for about 3k each,
and we're going to try selling them for
10k each.
Very good margin, and we'll be having
30k if we sell them. All right, we're
back, and I
The stupid arrow shafts have still not
sold, but the ancient stoles did sell
for 30k. So, about a 20k profit,
extremely good at this cash stack
amount. So, we finally have a little bit
more. We'll go put another offer in for
three, but we'll probably use this money
for something. So, one thing we want to
do is probably use a level one enchant
on some sapphire rings. That'll give us
some easy magic experience. While we can
only do about 13 at a time right now,
it's actually going to be profitable,
too, which will be nice. So, we're going
to have to do 13 at a time, rebuy them.
It'll be a pain in the ass, but we'll be
able to level up our magic pretty
quickly and then get the level two
enchant. All right, there we go. There
is level 15 magic. Really didn't take
too long at all. Going pretty quick. All
right, we have some quick flips coming
in. The arrow shafts finally sold off.
The ancient stoles we bought for about
3k each and sold them for a 9k each once
again. Flame tar hammers we bought for
really cheap as well, about 4k. So, we
got a 12k margin on that. And the bandos
pages only about 2k margin, but that
still leaves us with 75k, which is
awesome. There we go, that's 20 magic
just from using the level one enchant.
So, we should have a level two enchant
pretty soon, and then we can actually
get some better XP. All right, 25 magic,
only two more levels.
It's a little click intensive enchanting
these rings of recoil, but luckily,
we're actually making some money, so
we're actually up to about 115k just
from enchanting these rings. All right,
and that's going to be the final
inventory that will unlock the level two
enchant, another spell we can do right
from the grand exchange, and that's
going to increase our XP per hour by
about three times, which is pretty
exciting. One thing I just realized is
once I get my magic up to 43, I can use
the superheat spell. So, I can actually
get some smithing experience. That's
really exciting. 35 magic just from
enchanting these rings of dueling.
They're cheaper to buy, better
experience, so I'm really happy I got my
magic to this level at least. All right,
so while we're training our magic and
while we're just generally playing our
account, my account, I think I should at
least leave some flips in. So, I know
when the money comes through
often times I'll do overnight flipping,
but probably just having them in while
I'm playing is not a bad idea as well.
So, we're going to put an offer in for a
Guthix robe top for 42k, and we
insta-bought it. Well, it seems that it
should be able to sell for about 80k, so
that's not terrible. I guess we'll just
toss it right back in there
for well, 90k or something. And yeah,
look at that. Next up on GE tracker, we
are just using the highest margin page
once again. We filtered down our results
for about 100k. What here looks good?
Maybe well,
let's see. The rolling pin. That's a
good margin. A lot of people traded it
this last hour, so that's interesting.
Looks like there's actually a 15k
difference between the rolling pin.
So, [__] it, we'll give it a chance.
I've never bought this item before, but
let's toss in one rolling pin.
And then we'll put more Well, we got to
believe in the rolling pin. We'll go for
four. We insta bought the rolling pins
as well. Oh boy. All right, in the last
step we're going to put in an offer for
I think we want the green elegant legs
actually.
Uh yeah, G tracker is saying the green
elegant legs and we actually instantly
bought the rolling pins. So [__] me,
right? I don't really know what that
means, but we'll try to sell them for
34k. And we'll try buying these for
about 30 or 40k. All right, so we're
going to take this opportunity to level
up our fletching a little bit. Uh once
we get our fletching to a bit of a
higher level, we'll actually be able to
profit uh from our training. Right now
we're losing a bit of money, but anyway,
there's 10 fletching just padding our
total level pretty well. Another padding
of levels. There is 15 cooking just off
shrimps. Uh again, we're losing a little
bit of money here, but we have enough
now to kind of uh well, spend a little
bit to level our skills up. All right,
guys. So we have some successful flips
coming in. The Gothic top we bought for
about the 40k mark, so we're getting
about 40 50k profit on that. Uh the
rolling pins, about a 13k profit on each
of those, which is awesome. I saw there
I bought the cryer bells uh for 3k and
the black headband for 5k. So another
excellent profit on the cryer bells.
That was an insane margin. We managed to
snipe some items for very cheap. Uh so
we're left with about 350k mainly from
sniping these clue scroll items that
nobody wants. Uh when people dump them,
you can sometimes get them for really
good prices. Really easy way to build up
a stack of from nothing. Uh from now
we're going to actually go ahead and
flip some boots of darkness. Uh worked
really well in the past and we can buy
two sets for about 90k each and uh we'll
use the rest of the money to train. All
right, there's 25 cooking. We can now
cook salmon. All right, we're on to
cooking salmon and there we go. That is
35 cooking. Nice and quick skill. Now we
could cook tuna at this level, uh but we
might continue on with salmon.
No wait, what am I talking about? We'll
get tuna.
Uh like I said earlier, we are going to
get our combat levels up just by
training on these imps alone. It is very
slow, uh but we would like to get our
combat levels up uh because padding our
level will always help. And uh yeah, so
we're going to get five attack and
strength I think for now.
All right, there is level five attack.
We've also got level five strength. Uh
believe it or not, we're actually using
strength potions uh because it increases
our max hit by one. Uh these imps are
actually not bad money for the
circumstance anyway. I should have done
this right away uh cuz my inventory is
worth almost about 10k I think.
Uh yeah, 90 to 10k uh just in B drops.
So that would have been really useful.
But anyway, there we go.
All right, so before we head out, we're
going to toss in a couple more flips. Uh
the boots of darkness have not bought
yet, but we'll put an offer in for the
dragon chainbody ornament kit. Uh looks
like we may be able to snipe it for
around 50k, uh which would be awesome.
Uh and then we could probably sell for
100. I mean, these are items that really
make bank in the early stages of uh
well, how much money you have anyway. Uh
so we'll go ahead and try to buy two.
We'll go for 61k, be a little more
reasonable.
All right, guys. Uh so we have the final
flips coming in for the episode. We have
a bunch of imp drops we're just selling
in the bottom. All that sold. Uh the
final cryer bell for 34k, which is a
really good margin there. Uh the boots
of darkness we did end up selling for
134k and we bought them for about 80k.
Also, we tried to buy some ancient
chaps. That didn't end up working out,
but all in all, today we managed to grow
from nothing to about 455k,
uh which I think is really good for the
first episode. On top of that, uh we
ended up getting our total level to 145.
So only with 100 more total levels and
we can unlock the palace. And yeah,
that's about it, guys. So I really hope
you enjoy this series. Uh if you did or
are really excited for the future of it,
please leave the video like. I would
really appreciate it. And uh yeah,
thanks for watching, guys. I will see
you guys in episode number two.